das sagen alle deutschland und freue
mich dass sie dabei sind auch zu unserem
corona kompakt und erblicken wir unter
anderem gleich auf die dramatische
situation in einem pflegeheim in
wolfsburg außerdem geht es um das leben
in quarantäne
und es geht um ihre fragen heute
beantwortet von professor drexler von
der charité in berlin
zunächst aber der blick auf den heutigen
montag mit einer aufgeflogenen corona
party in stuttgart
sie haben die fenster abgedunkelt und
die musik leise gestellt und trotzdem
sind corona partygänger in zuffenhausen
aufgeflogen
13 streifenwagen müssen anrücken die
shisha bar wird zunächst umstellt und
dann zwangs geöffnet es ist der
dienstherr über 20 personen im keller
aufstöbert ob corona infizierte unter
den gästen waren muss noch festgestellt
werden
ihnen allen droht nun eine anzeige wegen
verstoßes gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz
damit sich alle an die regeln halten
geht der filialleiter eines
einkaufsmarktes im oberbergischen
lindlar ganz moderne wege abstand von ca
heißt dieser roboter er steht den kunden
während ihres einkaufes mit rat und tat
zur seite
die idee einen roboter einzusetzen hat
sich für den filialleiter mehr als
gelohnt erreicht eigentlich das was wir
erreichen wollten dass die botschaft
angenommen wird so hohen und bildern als
auch eine stimme hinterlegt ist und auch
wenn er nicht spricht wird er trotzdem
wahrgenommen weil er sich bewegt das
bereitet dem kunden im lächeln im
gesicht zumindest eine kleine chance und
man hat 14 15 kunden einfach den fokus
auf den roboter obwohl man ganz andere
probleme vielleicht im moment hat die
armen sind eine tolle gemeinschaft und
in jeder auf seine mitmenschen achtet
leben diele krise zusammen sehr gut
überstehen
angelika stecker dass johns hopkins
institut vermeldet heute 63 1079
infizierte und 9211 genießen zahlen auf
die auch immer unser experte guckt
unsere heutige experte auch bei corona
kompakter kommt aus berlin vom institut
für virologie an der charité
hallo professor jan felix drexler
unabhängig von der korona pandemie dann
beginnt er jetzt auch bei uns die
energie saison besteht für allergiker
ein größeres risiko am groner virus zu
erkranken
also man muss zunächst mal sagen kann
man kann das nur sicher noch gar nicht
beantworten wie ob überhaupt das risiko
dieser menschen erhöht ist dass man nur
feststellen muss ist dass man erst mal
sehr sehr gut nachvollziehen kann dass
diese dass diese patienten dass diese
menschen sich natürlich jetzt doppelt
bedroht fühlen weil sie eben ohnehin
lungen problematik haben und jetzt nun
mal
angst haben sich mit dem neuen kroner
virus zu infizieren
und ich glaube ganz entscheidend ist
dass diese patienten ganz eng mit ihrem
behandelnden arzt im haushalt zum
lungenfacharzt in kommunikation sind um
zum beispiel über die medikamente die
sie benutzen zu sprechen und das
gegebenenfalls anzupassen denn was auf
keinen fall passieren darf das ist klar
dass viele dieser patienten die zb
kortisonhaltige sprays inhalieren konnte
sohn ist ja ein ganz wichtiges
medikament für diese patienten und das
darf man natürlich nicht einfach
absetzen weil man sich jetzt sorgen
macht dass man deshalb empfänglicher
werden könnte was wir überhaupt nicht
wissen für eine krone virusinfektion
sondern das muss eben im engen austausch
mit dem behandelnden arzt besprochen
werden vieles ist eben noch neu bei dem
virus vielen dank erstmal für die
einschätzung und dafür dass sie sich
noch zeit nehmen für die fragen unserer
zuschauer also bis gleich das gleich
unabhängig von allergien das neuartige
kroner virus ist vor allem für menschen
mit vorerkrankungen und für ältere eine
große gefahr
wie sehr das zeigt auch die dramatische
entwicklung in einem wolfsburger alten
und pflegeheim 17 bewohner sind dort
inzwischen ein crooner virus gestorben
seit einer woche kommen sie regelmäßig
vorbei zum abtransportieren der toten
hier im hanns lilje pflegeheim in
wolfsburg sind seit letzten montag 17
menschen gestorben an dem corona virus
von 165 bewohnern sind inzwischen 79
infiziert alles ging überraschend
schnell
ich denke natürlich ganz viel lachen die
menschen die davon betroffen sind auch
die angehörigen die jetzt menschen
verlieren ohne dass sie dabei sind ohne
dass sie einen normalen abschied nehmen
können das finde ich schon so ziemlich
die stadt hatte noch am samstag geplant
das heim zu evakuieren
doch sie entschieden sich für einen
anderen weg aus rücksicht zu den schwer
demenzkranken bewohnern die einen
kompletten umzug nicht verkraftet hätten
alle infizierten wurden nun in ein
oberes stockwerk verlegt dieser bereich
wurde sehr intensiv gereinigt
desinfiziert geburt dort kam alles raus
was man eben nicht mit letzter
sicherheit desinfizieren kann wie zum
beispiel polstermöbel
die mit stoffen bezogen sind aber auch
die komplette kleidung alle persönlichen
gegenstände ein bild das an der wand
singen alters kam raus für unsere
bewohner ist das eine belastung
sondersgleichen es trifft die
schwächsten der schwachen die alten und
pflegeheime bundesweit sind keine
krankenhäuser
sie haben nicht automatisch genügend
schutzkleidung sie haben pflegenotstand
sind corona ausgeliefert bewohner und
pflegekräfte das virus kam offenbar
durch einen neu aufgenommenen bewohner
ins heim so genau wissen sie das nicht
niedersachsens gesundheitsministerin
reagiert kontakt reduktion ist es
wirklich zentrale thema deswegen die
betretungsverbote deswegen die
besuchsverbot wir werden aber jetzt
darüber hinaus noch verfügen dass keine
neuaufnahmen in hall mehr erfolgen
dürfen
das kurzzeitpflege nur noch in
singulären kurzzeitpflege erfolgen soll
oder in rehabilitationseinrichtungen die
wir dazu ermächtigen das aber das
allerwichtigste ist wirklich die
kontakte auf das minimum zu reduzieren
auch wenn es den angehörigen sehr schwer
fällt auch ein weiteres
niedersächsisches pflegeheim im
landkreis oldenburg kämpft gegen eine
infektionswelle 23 bewohner sowie 17
mitarbeiter sind mit 19 infizierten
mannes gestorben
der heimleiter fordert nun massentests
ungeziefer in den pflegeheimen in
deutschland wird sehr hoch sein da bin
ich schon überzeugt und das muss ich
überlegen
gib mir jetzt zu meisten testungen über
den künftigen überfordert man damit
natürlich das gesamte gesundheitssystem
ein schnelles ende der krise ist nicht
in sicht
und es gibt ja noch weitere
risikogruppen die ebenfalls äußerst
gefährdet sind wenn es zu einer coop 19
erkrankung kommt menschen mit einer
vorerkrankung nämlich so müssen im
klinikum stuttgart inzwischen immer mehr
dialyse patienten auf der
intensivstation betreut werden das ist
nur ein beispiel von vielen
es sind seltene einblicke die uns das
klinikum stuttgart gewehrt wir dürfen
auf der korona intensivstation filmen
weil ärzte und pflegekräfte zeigen
wollen dass an jedem beatmungsgerät ein
menschenleben hängt wer zu hause bleibt
kann leben retten das ist ihre botschaft
zwei mit corona infizierte dialyse
patienten liegen in diesem zimmer des
virus für sie besonders bedrohlich muss
ich einfach an strenge dass man mit
unbedingt mehr aushielt und auch nicht
groß mit anderen treffer für alle nur
inhofe kraftschluss personal für strong
groß alle intensivbetten sind
mittlerweile belegt die klinik versucht
noch mehr raum zu schaffen
es trifft nicht nur ältere und menschen
mit vorerkrankungen matthias ritter ist
gerade mal 33
trotzdem verlief die korona infektion
schwer zehn tage länger in der klinik
heute wird er entlassen
ich fühle mich schon noch ein bisschen
geschwächt habe es gemerkt beim treppe
hochlaufen dass man doch eher außer
puste kommt ja vor zehn tagen als sie
hier eingewiesen wurden wie war ihr
zustand mir ging es enorm schlecht ich
war schlaflos ich hatte hohes fieber
ich war kräfte los wie schnell eine
klinik in diesen zeiten an ihre grenzen
stößt zeigt sich am freitag im
nahegelegenen nürtingen weil es nicht
genügend beatmungs plätze gibt müssen
mehrere patienten in andere kliniken
geflogen werden
und schon jetzt fehlt es an
atemschutzmasken und
desinfektionsmitteln
es wird mittlerweile in unserer apotheke
selber schon der cfx ions mittel
hergestellt bei denen nicht mehr damit
ausreichend versorgt sind und wie es
nicht zulassen werden da sind wir
einhellig der meinung dass unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
ungeschützt als kanonenfutter die
patienten behandeln der höhepunkt der
korona krise steht noch bevor glauben
viele ärzte die ausgangs beschränkungen
lockern
diese diskussion käme viel zu früh es
ist menschlich dass alle hoffen dass
eine rückkehr zur normalität
dieser kontakt reduktion kommt im moment
wäre es fahrlässig und völlig falsch an
vielen deutschen kliniken kämpfen mit
corona infizierte menschen um ihr leben
wenn die zahlen weiter stark steigen
stoßen ärzte pflegekräfte kliniken an
ihre grenzen
und genau deshalb ist zu hause bleiben
weiter das gebot der stunde sei es
freiwillig oder eben ärztlich verordnet
sowie das ariana knöchel erlebt in ihrer
quarantäne eine 29 jährige biologin aus
berlin
die dadurch weiß wovon sie spricht
ariana knöchel 29 jahre corona positiv
die berliner biologin beschäftigt sich
intensiv mit ihrer krankheit um seriös
zu informieren und auch aus wut auf die
vielen falschmeldungen im netz beginnt
sie bei instagram ein quarantäne
tagebuch zu führen
die banken erst corinnas blöd alles nur
panikmache
andere waren komplett in panik versetzt
und haben auch einfach so wie fake news
verbreitet und da bin ich als sehr
aufgebracht geworden weil ich hab selber
sehr viel recherchiert und wurde
sozusagen die leute gerade drücken und
sagen du hast kannst du nicht posten
hört auf damit
da bin ich als er wütend geworden habe
ich gelernt
angefangen hat alles an diesem abend in
berlin es war noch vor den warnungen
größere menschenansammlungen zu meiden
eine der freundinnen feiert in einem
angesagten club der hauptstadt ihren
geburtstag
es war nach eng alle haben geschwitzt
alle herum gegrölt alle waren betrunken
und ja wir sind dann einfach danach alle
unsere wege gegangen nach hause und dann
am freitag habe ich von meinen mädels im
gruppenchat eine nachricht bekommen mit
dem artikel
alle die in der trompete waren ihr müsst
ihr nach hause ist dem gesundheitsamt
schreiben hier ist die e-mail ein
crooner infizierter war da immer sofort
nach hause
ariana knöchel begibt sich wie die
anderen in quarantäne und meldet sich
beim gesundheitsamt das ruft zwei der
freundinnen die nach leipzig gereist
waren
zurück nach berlin kam am sonntag die
migranten mitgebracht haben abstrich die
muss ich dann tatsächlich selber machen
vor meinem badezimmer spiegel bei sie
halt keine schutzausrüstung mehr hatte
oder am dienstag hatte ich ein ergebnis
positiv sie haben corona
wie zwei andere freundinnen aus der
gruppe deren symptome sind allerdings
schwächer sie müssen zu einer der
zentralen test stellen gehen um sich
dort testen zu lassen
ariana geht es von allen am
schlechtesten nach dem dritten tag wo
wir im glück waren habe ich gemerkt dass
ich diesen trockenen husten bekommen
habe und er sind auch relativ schnell
dollar geworden
und dann habe ich auch gemerkt dass ich
den immer so gegen abend hin so ein
bisschen schüttelfrost bekommen habe
einfach ein bisschen kalt da waren wir
wieder ein bisschen warm dann hatte ich
auch einmal kurz erhöhte temperatur aber
auch wirklich nur einen abend aber nach
ein paar tagen wo ich dachte mir geht es
besser
dass sie dann halt auch keine symptome
mehr richtig gezeigt was den husten
angeht hatte ich dann aber am nächsten
tag das gefühl dass es mir halt tausend
mal schlechter ging ich lag die ganze
zeit nur an einer stelle und habe
versucht bloß mich nicht zu bewegen weil
mir hat so übel war und ich hatte halt
angst weil ich nicht wusste habe ich
jetzt fiebere und nicht im bett und
kriegen lungenentzündung
die amtsärztin stellt fest des areals
kreislauf völlig im keller ist die
ärztin rät zu täglicher bewegung auch in
der quarantäne
seitdem trainiert ariana und versucht
sich fit zu halten
man muss einfach nur seinen gesunden
menschenverstand benutzen
und egal was für verschwörungstheorien
in umlauf gerade sind es geht einfach
darum leute nicht mehr anzustecken
wie macht man das man nachts zu hause
einfach
offensichtlich nicht für alle so einfach
stimmt außerdem gibt es ja auch dort
diverse herausforderungen zu hause sowie
innen rasmussen und carsten hansen die
zu meistern haben das deutsch-dänische
liebespaar aus der grenzregion hat
nämlich getrennte wohnsitze dies und
jenseits der grenze tja und der kroner
krise ist eben diese genau auch jetzt
inzwischen geschlossen
doch liebe kennt keine grenzen rasmussen
kommt mit dem auto aus dem dänischen
aarhus kosten hansen mit dem rad aus
süderlügum in deutschland seit die
grenze zwischen deutschland und dänemark
geschlossen hast treffen sich die beiden
verliebten täglich um 15 uhr am
grenzübergang in abend trifft zum
kaffeetrinken klönen und kekse sind
dennoch bleiben und ich muss im
deutschen bleiben und das macht nämlich
glauben oder fragt sie andere leute
das geht nicht das geht nicht ich sagte
doch auch ich habe doch gefragt
sie wollte das gar nicht hier hin aber
ich habe sie noch über überzeugt
eine liebe am schlagbaum doch weder eine
umarmung noch ein küsschen gibt es
während der gemeinsamen zeit in madrid
und die zwei meter abstandsregelung
heißt sie sich natürlich aber das geht
auch schon gefunkt hat es zwischen der
85 jährigen und dem 89 jährigen vor zwei
jahren in einem supermarkt alles begann
mit einem blumenstrauß und einer
kenntnis seitdem sind die beiden uns
verständigen probleme gibt es keine
er spricht fließend englisch sie
fließend deutsch
liebe kennt eben keine grenzen
ich habe ja immer zu meinen töchtern
gesagt die gehen ja zu sagen heuer ihr
kommt mit einem deutschen nach hause und
das war nicht mal dass ein deutscher war
das war bloß ich weiß nicht vielleicht
kann dass sie ganz nach süddeutschland
oder nach ich weiß nicht wohin ich
sollten dem nehmen damit in dänemark
bleiben können und jetzt selbst ja da
liegt ja was machst du jetzt motto jetzt
hast du ja deutschen ringer und carsten
machen das beste aus der zeit in der
liebe und nähe nur mit abstand möglich
sind und spielen pläne für die zeit nach
kona das wird nicht langweilig führen
deutsch dänisches runde an der grenze
auf die liebe
von dem wohl romantischsten schlagbaum
des landes jetzt in die hauptstadt an
die berliner charité von bones aus der
virologe professor jan felix drexler
zugeschaltet ist wir haben es ja schon
mal eben gehört starten wir direkt mit
den zuschauerfragen so fragt herr oder
frau hecht woher weiß man dass eine 14
tägige quarantäne
nach einer infektion mit dem norovirus
ausreichend ist obwohl es eben noch
keinen abschluss test gibt das wissen
wir deshalb weil wir ausreichende daten
inzwischen von patienten haben und sehen
wie lange die menschen trotz all der
unterschiede zwischen einzelnen menschen
noch infektiös sind
das heißt wir können sicher sagen dass
man mit den 14 tagen auf jeden fall im
grünen bereich liegt das schon mal gut
zu wissen passt doch die frage von
milena man hofer zu kann nicht testen
lassen ob ich unwissentlich bereits eine
cola infektion hatte also was ist danach
ja das geht die tests dafür sind
eigentlich gerade erst auf den markt
gekommen und es werden auch noch weitere
test entwickelt und von firmen von
wissenschaftlern das geht indem man aus
einer blutprobe also nicht aus einem
rachenabstrich wie sie das vorhandene
den beitrag gesehen haben sondern aus
einer blutprobe die man ihnen abnimmt
antikörper gegen das sei ascona virus 2
bestimmt
denn in ihrem blut solche antikörper die
dann auch tatsächlich spezifisch für
dieses virus sein müssen
man braucht also gute testverfahren dann
kann man sagen sie haben eine infektion
durchgemacht und nach allem was wir
momentan wissen können wir mit einiger
sicherheit davon ausgehen dass dieses
infektion durchgemacht haben auch
bedeutet dass sie wahrscheinlich immun
sind wahrscheinlich so genau wissen halt
eben noch nicht aber wir können ziemlich
sicher davon ausgehen dass wir jetzt auf
meine frage gewesen also hat sich das
inzwischen weiterentwickelt dieses
wissen ohne hundertprozentige sicherheit
aber das ist doch schon mal ein weitere
sachverhalt den wir mitnehmen
grewer b gräber fragt entschuldigung
kann das virus auch über stechmücken und
zecken übertragen werden
na also dass es gibt zwei arten wie
solche insekten viren übertragen können
die eine ist rein mechanisch das also
einfach blut von einer blutmahlzeit noch
am saupurzel zb
hängt und ein anderer wird gestochen
wird und dabei ein infiziertes virus in
operiert wird
das ist aber für corona nie gezeigt
worden und eigentlich auch undenkbar und
die zweite möglichkeit wäre die
klassische da denken müssen sie es gibt
ja viele durch mücken übertragen der
rega wie dengue virus oder das c a virus
die wirklich einen lebenszyklus in der
mücke haben und in der werke
vervielfältigt werden und sich im
speicher in den speicheldrüsen der mücke
anreichern oder der zecke je nachdem um
dann in großen mengen in den band beim
staatsakt abgesondert zu werden und das
gilt für krone auf keinen fall also da
muss man sich überhaupt keine sorgen
machen
eine letzte frage noch kurze antwort
wenn möglich es geht um das händewaschen
barbara schwimmern verträgt dann nämlich
keine richtige seife und nimmt seifen
freie was stücke ist das auch okay oder
würde andere seife sie besser schützen
also ganz generell sind krone gehüllt
das heißt sie haben eine eine
fettschicht wenn sie so wollen außen um
das virus cup sieht also um die proteine
hülle des virus und diese fettschicht
ist labil die geht also durch sein für
kaputt und ohne dass ich genau weiß was
seifen freie war stücke genau sind würde
ich behaupten dass das ziemlich sicher
sein dürfte wahrscheinlich reicht das
auch schon wenn sie sich mit warmem
wasser die hände waschen was nicht
heißen soll dass sie keine seife
benutzen sollen aber wenn sie ein grund
grund haben eben diese zum beispiel mit
seife probleme haben dass ihre haut
darauf nicht gut reagiert dann denke ich
können sie ruhig damit weiter waschen
solange sie waschen und sich ein
allgemeiner grundregeln halten der
hygiene und damit sage ich danke
professor jan felix drexler für ihre
zeit und alle antworten im rahmen
hiervon kroner kompakt ja genau das
finden sie auch täglich neu auf youtube
und zwar auf dem kanal der zdf- heute-
und dafür können sie uns weiter ihre
fragen schicken an unsere experten
corona kompakte zdf ist da die adresse